i know what you're thinking but i've
watched every youtube video seen every
tips and tricks guide i know everything
already
well i guarantee you even after four
long years of breath of the wild being
released
even seasoned veterans will learn at
least one thing new here today this list
includes regular secrets and some
glitches ranging from simple to complex
things
so if you enjoy content like this let us
know by giving us a simple like
it helps more than you think alright
let's jump right in
henox's style knox that attack with
trees will obviously damage link but if
they happen to pick up a bent palm tree
this will mislink completely because of
the bent hitbox of the tree
henoxes that do sweeping attacks with
longer trees can be ducked under
hyrule castle batteries actually work as
real intended batteries
blocking incoming guardian lasers while
letting you fire through them only in
hyrule castle all champion abilities
have much shorter cooldown this also
stacks with the room plus upgrades
outside of hyrule castle the cooldown is
normal link has multiple small
animations and sounds you may have
missed for different types of food he
consumes
such as skewers dishes rock hard food
dubious food drinking elixirs or milk
eating raw ingredients
and manually using a fairy you can
instant spin attack with a sword by
spinning the stick then attacking
but the direction of the spin attack
reflects the direction that you spun the
stick
holding zl while swimming will give you
a different swim animation
this is a direct reference to ocarina of
time's swim animation
if you see a lynel starting to charge
you either hold an item
a bow or a bomb in your hand hold zl
then just
pop backwards you'll strangely dodge
right through its charge
moblins with spears have a special
lunging spirit attack that has a huge
flurry rush window
it's such a large window that you can
flurry rush the same attack twice
in kakariko there is one singular apple
that someone hid
underneath this bridge
[Music]
farm animals like sheep and cows conduct
electricity weird thing is when they
conduct it to you
it doesn't harm you maybe it's because
of the wool
on death mountain you'll usually burn to
a crisp without the right gear or elixir
but you can reset your burn timer by
spin attacking with a heavy weapon
you can also simply douse yourself with
a regular choo choo jelly to get 30
seconds of heat invulnerability
this also works in the hot gerudo desert
speaking of the gerudo desert if you're
completely out of shade and are burning
up you can use a large weapon such as a
crusher above your head as
shade funnily enough this also makes you
walk faster than normally wading through
sand
everyone reacts pretty similarly to you
pulling out a bomb in front of them
with most key characters having a little
more special dialogue but the weirdest
dialogue is with oakland the pumpkin
farmer at night
when he's not farming in which he'll say
this
in master mode all enemies are upgraded
one level which means there are no low
level red bokoblins
except for one lonely one in the world
riding a horse below the stasis shrine
there are technically three distances
you could throw an item pressing d-pad
down will far throw a regular throw will
go right in front of you
and using magnesius first then throwing
will drop it right at your feet
it's possible to play breath of the wild
in first person using a glitch
but it's pretty difficult to pull off
but we do have a guide all about it
when you run out of arrows in your
quiver not only is your quiver empty but
your stance changes as well
and firing the bow with no arrows will
just make a strumming noise
you can lift the style knocks up with
the magnesius chest they will get pretty
pissed though and start throwing
explosive barrels at you
if a bokoblin is unarmed and tries to
melee you stand still and parry over and
over
your slight forward momentum and the
bokoblin's strange attack angle puts you
in a perpetual state of missing high
fives
every large enemy in the world can be
crouched under this includes guardians
lionels and taluses
henox's can be run under
if you have completed the champion's
ballot dlc warp to the divine beast
varuta
look up and wait 30 seconds for a really
weird surprise
pebbles can be picked up and thrown or
dropped to defeat them
but you can also simply run them over
with the master cycle
the master cycle also has a very strange
glitch to the rear tire specifically
you can gain bullet time straight from
the ground over the rear tire at a 45
degree angle
now you can really win bomb anywhere
the eye is not the guardian's only weak
spot the blue engine on the bottom is
also a weak spot as well
at the lake of kala ferry fountain
there's a massive hole in the wall that
developers forgot to fill in correctly
there are actually several of these
hidden throughout hyrule as well with
how big hyrule is
this was bound to happen most people
know about using sunshrooms and spicy
peppers as updrafts but they can also be
chained together as long as you don't
directly shoot the ingredient
just shoot right next to it to set it on
fire and then you'll get a secondary
updraft
if you fire single shot regular arrows
at a wooden boomerang while it's
returning
you can completely cover a wooden
boomerang with arrows and even
sheath it at this point you can retrieve
your arrows back whenever you want
sort of becoming an arrow pin cushion in
hoteno village the villagers will have
special dialogue and even some small
rewards when you carry around a blue
flame but also the kids will surround
you and admire the pretty flame
[Music]
with certain glitch techniques link
actually has the ability to body slam
his opponents
by thunderclap rushing pressing b then
unequipping your weapon
or by skew bouncing above the enemy's
head link's own body momentum smacks the
enemy doing 8 damage
when you exit the scope you're
temporarily invisible use flurry rushes
or bullet time to extend that time
and look invisible
if you're stuck out in a storm or rain
cut down a tree stasis it really quickly
then throw some wood underneath it
this is basically a mini roof allowing
you to make a fire while it's raining to
pass the time
break the tree down to get your bundle
of wood back
if you ever looked closely at your map
while being attacked by guardians all
the ones who have noticed you will be
posting red on your map
ones who have lost track of you but are
still alert are pinged as a regular red
dot
if you land on top of a guardian jump
then shield surf on top of it
you can just chill here like this and
the guardian won't move
when targeted by a guardian try and
selfie pose it will sometimes target the
camera instead of link
you might need to buy a new selfie stick
at this point if you're ever out of
stamina
hold zl and walk instead it's faster
than normally walking
in one of the buildings in gerudo town
there's a scarecrow with a funny
hand-drawn face on it
the gerudo risa uses it to practice
pickup lines for vo men
in secret moblins that throw their
friend bokoblins do damage depending on
the throne bokoblin's melee damage
not the moblin's throwing damage
throwing live animals off a tall ledge
will make them float
strangely also releasing any live animal
normally will
make them run away but if you hold the
animals throw them
then bomb yourself very quickly they
will spawn in normally
you can make a swarm of animals anywhere
this way this specific technique is also
used to get extra fairies
and can be used to get a total of 21
fairies this way
when near cooking pot the game will
automatically bring up the food
ingredients menu no matter which menu
you were in before
because it knows you want to cook when
you find a ring of rocks for a missing
clorox seed stand in the middle and look
in the direction of the missing rock
it'll always point you in the general
direction of where you should start
looking
you can disable a guardian and have it
be friendly by using urbosa's fury
then using stasis it will simply sit
there and look around aimlessly
and it won't care even if you attack it
you can also do a visual delayed
thunderstrike on a guardian
by using urbosa's fury twice in quick
succession the second lightning strike
will come 8 seconds later
it looks pretty epic in slow motion
if you continue to beat the champion's
ballad blights over and over you will
continue to get unique dialogue and lore
for each champion
including some pretty amazing voice
lines you should find my diary somewhere
don't you dare read it the stone smasher
boulder breaker and lino crushers all
have a special property
they're all heavy enough to push stone
objects when magnesis
this includes stone switches anvils and
even open
and closed stone doors this can't be
done with any other weapons
and that's it breath of the wild is a
journey that doesn't stop and there's
always something new to learn
even for veterans such as myself if you
enjoy breath of the wild content like
this be sure to check out our other
content including expert reacts and
breakdown videos
and for everything else stay tuned right
here on gamespot